exaspéré nous dit c'est tout citoyen
danis tension luc ferrandez bonjour
bonsoir bon j'avoue j'ai l'expérience
pourquoi c'est si long année c'est
compliqué parce que c'est la
responsabilité de chacun des
arrondissements depuis que la ville de
montréal s'est fusionnée chaque
arrondissement est responsable de son
développement économique cependant il ya
des façons de faire puis à des choses
qu'on doit jamais oublier c'est que
l'arrondissement est au service de sa
population sipa la population qui est au
service des autres on est là pour rendre
des services quand les gens veulent
construire premièrement c'est la vache à
lait de l'arrondissement les produits
les revenus des permis reste de
l'arrondissement et s'il ya des
arrondissements qu'ils n'ont pas trop
compris et nous chez nous en tout cas
quand on est arrivé on a mis ça en place
ont ceci dit quand quelqu'un vient voir
puis on peut y mettre le permis le plus
rapidement possible parce que ça
respecte les règles le cadre bâti les
règlements d'urbanisme selon les passes
en 24 heures pas de problème quand il y
en a qui doivent passer au comité
consultatif d'urbanisme
c'est paul histoire qui se met là à
attendre on dit parfait on regarde votre
dossier puis prochain cce qui est de la
place on voit le soc pour les ongs
roddick l'a laissé ses juges pour des
grosses affaires c'est justement pour
ceux qui peuvent pas la voir en 24 à 36
heures parce que c'est ça respecte les
règlements donc les plus gros ça peut
prendre un mois deux mois soit scellé
les plus gros il y en a des migros
centre-ville c'est autre chose on est de
façon générale les citoyens n'ont pas à
attendre aussi longtemps pour des
dossiers comme ceux là et il faut
vraiment que les élus les nouveaux s'en
viennent soit aussi conscient de ça les
patrons ce sont les citoyens les
fonctionnaires et les élus sont au
service des citoyens c'est un service
qu'on a et ceux qui veulent vraiment
bien géré mais c'est de l'argent qui
rentre luc ferrandez j'avais connus sont
aussi un lot plateau ça s'est dégradé
par rapport à autrefois mais peu importe
comment ça se fait c'est le manque de
personnel quoi comment se fait que ces
subventions plusieurs chaudes ya trois
types d'interventions une intervention
l'intérieur seulement ça prend un permis
c'est uniquement un permis pour être
conforme au code de la construction donc
quand la designer disait bd fois je le
recommande d'aller sans permis à
l'intérieur faut avouer que c'est moins
grave ensuite de ça il ya l'intervention
à l'extérieur mais c'est moins grave
vous êtes même qu'on est obligé d'en
avoir un
n'allez pas chercher un c'est juste
alors je ne dis pas ça mais je dis que
une intervention d'intérieur l'émission
permis nécessite beaucoup moins de
travail parce que tout ce qu'on va
regarder c est ce que c'est conforme au
code de construction que c'est si long à
cause personnelle l'offre et la demande
il ya beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
rénovations et les travaux qui
nécessitent des changements
architecturaux des agrandissements ou
des démolitions faut que ça soit trois
lectures en conseil et ça passe en
comité démolition et ça passe en cce
comme le dit annie et c'est une bonne
chose parce que des maisons qui se sont
construits des mezzanines qui ont fait
de l'ombre entièrement sur le seul
espace habitable de la voiture d'en face
ou qui ont été obligés de couper tous
les arbres de la cour arrière ou qui
l'ont fait plus haut que le code de
construction ça plus dans les
arrondissements alors ça prend un permis
pour tout agrandissement démolition
transformation des façades c'est
exigible mais là il faut avoir le
personnel et les étapes d'intervention
sont longues alors moi je recommande
vraiment pas à la dame qui disait je
pense d'y aller sans permis je
recommande vraiment pas de faire ça d
énormes contraventions des arrêts de
chantier à vos perdre son entrepreneur
ne fait pas ça madame oui mais vous la
comprenez des excès d bien sûr bien sûr
et écoute le écoutez le le poste d'agent
qui reçoit les demandes de permis c'est
un poste d'entrée à la ville de montréal
les architectes ils veulent pas faire je
sors dans la vie dès qu'ils ont un peu
d'expérience ils partent ailleurs alors
c'est très difficile de recruter et le
yoyo un gel de toutes les dépenses à
l'inter est ce qu'on peut simplifier
annie et le clou rapidement je passais
le tuer ce qu'ont pu simplifier le
processus un peu là peut être parce que
ça on peut simplifier compliqué on met
de côté puisque est simple on le passe
vite une façon d'organiser le travail et
c'est faisable c'est faisable parce que
c'est totalement illogique de faire
attendre des familles six mois sont vus
qui restent à montréal les aider à
grandir leur maison pour leurs familles
si si c'est images il est très possible
de le faire pour les portes des fenêtres
les façades arrières l'intérieur des
maisons c'est possible de le faire et
plusieurs autres soit le font déjà très
bien les plus grosses interventions
c'est plus difficile bon
onze jours
madame plein qui veut faire de montréal
une ville
de la nordiste est un peu déjà comme un
aveu prendre l'hiver plus festif plus
joyeux elle veut et ça je trouve ça
intéressant dans des parcs lui que je
vous entends de là dessus et annie
envoyé de la neige pour qu'on puisse
glisser parce qu'on sait que il manque
de neige
des fois des toutes petites
interventions comme la piste de ski de
fond qui est émise dans le parc
lafontaine ont un effet spectaculaire et
il faut faire des petites interventions
comme sa folie multi essentiellement
chanté de ce qu'ils font faut pas
oublier que notre hiver avant on avait
trois quatre cycles de gel dégel
maintenant on en a vingt pas l'hiver
alors une neige suivie d'un verglas fini
de vue de alors ça coûte de la pluie
souvent ça coûte très très cher de
remettre au jour sur l'intervention
c'est pour ça qu'elles doivent être
modeste année moi je trouve ça important
on sait depuis la coved les gens sont
habitués de sortir été comme hiver au
printemps l'automne pendant leur marche
nous dans le parc jarry on ne fait une
piste de ski de fond à la demande des
citoyens qui ont été adoré on a un quart
temps mais ce que j'ai aimé du projet de
mal à placer les terrasses les terrasses
où on va enfin peut-être pouvoir
permettre les réchauffe le sco mais
puisque actuellement assez pop et remis
ça permettrait de des régions parce que
je me trompe mais c'est encore des rays
a mis la chloration municipal parlons
quand même faut parler du projet de
monsieur coderre dans l'est de montréal
il faut revoir il propose de faire plus
de citations du rem vos commentaires le
quai annie ensuite sur l'est de montréal
je je je n'en reviens pas je comprends
toujours pas quelqu'un qu'on me
l'expliqué un jour pourquoi on s'obstine
à faire uniquement de l'industriel le
coup d'industriels gros municipalité
c'est énorme en termes d'infrastructures
de transports en terme d'accueil du quai
des goûts en termes de décontamination
je pense que si on veut vraiment
transformé l'est il faut beaucoup penser
au résidentiel année moi je pense que la
mx qui est la mixité est importante on
disait qu'on voulait faire plus d
espaces verts la boxe ce soit plus sur
le plan environnemental accessible
actuellement il y en a des compagnies on
peut pas les enlever ça crée des emplois
à montréal sarah ça rapporte beaucoup de
taxes aussi il faut aussi le verdict je
pense que cette mixité lloyd quand même
de bonne augure de le fait que le rem ce
rôle là il y aura aussi beaucoup plus
d'impôts au niveau d'économies pour les
citoyens qui restent qui pourront
travailler dans le même secteur aussi
est-ce que vous chantez quelques
secondes chacun que la campagne
s'accélère quand on change de rythme ni
oui oui avec les annonces et tous les
jours il y en a plein maintenant on est
plus tard de finir délire qui en est des
nouvelles qui arrivent c'est noël tous
les jours c'est intéressant mais comme
je vous dis j'ai hâte qu'on puisse voir
le bilan de financer combien ça va
coûter toutes ces belles promesses c'est
important aussi l'udc rien à ajouter
c'est vrai que la halle une demande par
jour une annonce par jour c'est est ce
qu'il ya fait la popularité de madame
perdre à la dernière exemple monsieur
coda est là reprend ça donne un bon
match parlant de match match revanche
lundi prochain sus aux ondes une heure
un face à face entre denis coderre et
valérie plan 2 les deux principaux
candidats seuls avec il y aura des
quelques questions du citoyen
préenregistrés irano question et il y
aura surtout le débat le plus libre
possible
18h01 heure complète sur radio canada et
rdi on voudra bien sûr vous entendent
ensuite merci à vous deux bonne soirée
au revoir